well let's bring in white house deputy
press secretary brian morgenstern brian
always great to have you
uh take a listen to senator dick durbin
his thoughts about
what's happened with this hack
virtually a declaration of war by russia
on the united states and we should take
that seriously
ryan does the white house believe that
this was a declaration of war
well dana thank you for having me back
it's great to be back
um what i would say is that we are
taking this extremely seriously there is
an interagency working group meeting
every day sometimes multiple times a day
as i speak to you now
the national security advisor ambassador
o'brien is in the situation room working
on this there are incident response
teams at numerous government agencies
with expertise
in this area that includes the fbi the
nsa
dhs and the office of the director of
national intelligence
we are working hard on this to mitigate
any potential effects
to make sure that our country is secure
going forward one thing that we will not
do
is tell our adversaries exactly how we
are combating
their malign activities but rest assured
we have the best and brightest in our
government
working very hard on this issue as we
speak
i mean i think that that is something
that you know members of congress can
say
sir uh that it's a declaration of war
but when you are responsible
uh for the actual execution uh you have
to keep things
under wraps so we appreciate that indeed
um i want to ask you about covet relief
bill because
i i can't imagine how frustrated
the president might be with capitol hill
that it's still not done
can you give us a sense of how he's
thinking about this
yeah absolutely dana the president wants
to deliver relief
to the american people before christmas
before we head into the holidays
and it's something it's the priorities
that he's been talking about really for
months it's
ppp for small businesses it's stimulus
checks
to families it's unemployment insurance
we want to get schools
open we want to make sure the vaccines
are delivered timely
it's things that are critical to the
american people in response to the
coronavirus
these priorities really haven't changed
what has changed is that
the democrats seem to keep moving the
goal posts but over the past
uh number of days we've seen renewed
optimism from senator mcconnell
uh we think he seems to be closing the
gap we're supportive of
his efforts and we're hopeful that we're
going to get a deal to keep the
government open
and to deliver relief to the american
people before the holidays we remain
engaged
and really projecting optimism and
enthusiasm
that we will get this done
every holiday season we go through this
i remember the first time in 1995 i've
worked on capitol hill didn't know if i
was going to get to go home but they
finally got it done at the
last minute hopefully they'll do that
again wanted to show just a little bit
of
vice president pence getting the vaccine
this morning
and you know that was that was quite a
moment um
let's let's just get your take on this
because i know you've worked very
closely on operation warp speed
yes uh thank you and the vice president
has has worked a lot on this of course
it's
you know the president uh really brought
together the scientific community
the military the private sector uh very
strong leadership to accomplish
something that all the
so-called experts said was impossible
the trump administration
uh has made it so that we have safe and
effective vaccines this year
the vice president of course very proud
of those efforts and was happy to
project confidence the american people
that indeed these vaccines are safe and
effective no corners were cut with
respect to safety
it was investments and it was improved
coordination
that really sped up this timeline to get
it done five times faster than ever
before
so i know the vice president's very
proud to have taken the shot and to show
the american people
that they should take the shots too so
that we can see the end of this pandemic
as soon as possible
amen to that indeed brian morgenstern
thank you have a good weekend
thanks dani